هذا وحذرت منظمه الاغذيه والزراعه التابعه
للامم المتحده من احتمالات تفاقم الجوع في
العالم وحدوث تداعيات بعيده المدى بيئيا
وانسانيا جراء تفجير السنه وقال المتحدث
باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده ستيفان
دوجاريك ان تدمير السد سيؤثر بشكل سلبيا
على الامن الغذائي في العالم بعد تدمير
الفيضانات الاف الهكتارات من الاراضي
الزراعيه
تحذر منظمه الاغذيه والزراعه التابعه
للامم المتحده من ان التدمير السد سيؤثر
على الارجح على الامن الغذائي حيث غمرت
المياه الاف الهكتارات من الاراضي
الزراعيه مما ادى الى تدمير المحاصيل
المزروعه مؤخرا وتقول السلطات ان تدمير
السد اهلك نظام الري في مناطق
من ناحيه الاستجابه نعمل دون توقف لتزويد
المجتمعات المتاثره بالمساعده بقدر ما
يمكننا تقديمه وتلبيه احتياجاتهم